bonsoir à tous bienvenue à cette
émission spéciale de découverte en
direct ihsan marie dussault ici charles
cher bonsoir ça fait maintenant deux ans
qu'un mystérieux virus apparaissait à
one en chine un virus qui au fil des
mutations a bouleversé nos vies
tellement bouleversé nos vies charles
qu'il y a deux ans vous et moi on se
retrouvait sur un plateau c'est de
comprendre ce que cette pandémie
signifiait pour nous ici au pays mais
aussi partout dans le monde et il faut
faire ce qu'il faut se rappeler les
chiffres du moment en mars 2020 le 15
mars elle soir de notre émission on
recensait 321 cas au pays 39 au québec
un seul décès et deux ans plus tard on
compte 3 millions d'infections
31000 canadiens en sont morts mais
depuis il faut le dire il ya un grand
bout de chemin qui a été fait deux
heures plus tard on se demande donc à
quand la fin pouvons-nous même espérer
une fin encore tout le monde vous pose
la question nous la pause à 24,60 on a
des invités ce soir qui vont répondre à
cette question en fait la question et
tout ça est ce qu'il ya une date de
péremption de cette pandémie calendrier
où on peut dire oui ce sera ce mois là
cette saison là en espérant que ce soit
pas encore quelques années il face à
toutes ces incertitudes
un phare nous guident la science
toujours et encore et c'est votre métier
charge oui et celui de mes collègues la
découverte et donc c'est la question
qu'on se pose ce soir qu'est ce que la
chance nous a appris deux ans plus tard
et ce qu'elle prévoit alors au cours des
90 prochaines minutes plusieurs experts
vont répondre à nos questions mais aussi
aux veaux autres et je vous les présente
enfin je suis pas vraiment besoin de
présentation vous les connaissez
puisqu'ils ont été des ressources
inestimables dans ce long combat contre
la co lead dr cécile tremblay
microbiologiste-infectiologue bonsoir dr
tremblay merci d'être là bonsoir à tenir
bon dans les mers conseiller
scientifique en chef du canada merci
madame le maire dette avec nous ce soir
encore bonsoir c'est un plaisir merci
karl weiss microbiologiste infectiologue
aucun vice bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous auriez-vous soir bonsoir
auriez-vous
que depuis mars 2000 mais en 2020 on
sera encore ce soir sur ce plateau a
parlé de la confiture c'est ce qu'on est
à un point tournant docteur tard blé
mais au début on se doutait pas que ça
durerait aussi longtemps personne sans
doute et puis je dirais même que c'est
probablement une des raisons pourquoi
malgré les nombreux plans de pandémie
que tous les pays avaient on était si
peu préparé à une pandémie qui durerait
aussi longtemps
on n'avait plus l'impression que ce
serait quelque chose de peut-être grade
mais consentirait rapidement alors alors
oui on va s'en tirer mais peut-être pas
sur la même vitesse que l'on aurait
souhaité et faut penser donc à des
accroches qui vont être plus sur le long
terme pour nous sortir du marasme allons
vers eux on se revoit dans deux ans
tremblay pour par le point encore mon
année maire de votre point de vue à vous
comme dirait scientifique en chef et
puis moi non plus je pensais pas qu'on
allait avoir le virus aussi pandémique
pendant deux ans d'autre part je ne
croyais pas qu'on apprendrez aussi vite
des choses sur ce virus qu'on
développerait des vaccins et qu'on
vaccine ray la moitié de la planète là
en l'espace d'une année donc il ya quand
même la du bon qui s'est produit donc
c'est une source d'émerveillement pour
vous si je comprends bien disons que oui
l'émerveillement dans les conditions ni
la gravité de la situation quand on voit
le nombre de morts est absolument épiler
pour vous dr weiss
moi je vous dirais qu'une pandémie ont
regardé ça sur un échéancier de six mois
et man mais d'un autre côté
historiquement toutes les pandémies ont
duré plusieurs années donc il y avait de
gros point d'interrogation
la seule chose qu'on peut dire c'est que
jamais dans l'histoire on a avancé aussi
rapidement pour autant de choses
lorsqu'un virus est arrivé sur la
planète en si peu de temps donc il ya
quand même de bonnes choses et à la
question est ce qu'il y aura une fin il
y aura certainement une fin la question
c'est qu'on connaît pas la date on
connaît pas la date on va la découvrir
ensemble éventuellement de les continuer
de nous accompagner mais vous nous
donner beaucoup d'espoir tous les trois
ce soir et vous allez nous expliquer le
chemin qui reste à parcourir aussi pour
y arriver merci on se retrouve dans un
instant parce que ces variants charles
ils ont emporté des noms comme l alfa
des le camus aimait passer au micron la
source originale de l'aco vide a connu
tellement de mutation mais parmi les
dizaines de questions que nous avons
reçus en vue de cette émission parce
qu'on vous a lancé un appel via les
réseaux sociaux une soirée les trois
rivières
caroline darche qui aimera comprend
comment sait-il que ce variantes soit 6
comte sgp styles de tous pris par
surprise au micro absolument et on
constate effectivement que il est plus
contagieux mais il est moins sévère
alors pour comprendre le variant au mit
au micro je devrais commencer à savoir
comment
on oublie comme on dit en anciens grecs
effectivement voici un reportage que mes
collègues de découverte et moi même
avons préparé pour mieux comprendre
[Musique]
depuis deux mois le mot est sur toutes
les lèvres
variant au micro le variant s'est
répandue sur la planète comme une
traînée de poudre micronésie probably
emos cancelli cas sont plus nombreux que
jamais les systèmes de santé crack la
situation dans les prochaines semaines
elle doit être critique des incertitudes
sont nombreuses mais que sait-on
vraiment sûr au micro
[Musique]
26 novembre 2000 va dire la propagation
du virus en afrique du sud et au
botswana attire l'attention de louer
baisse soudaine envie - est une vérité
une nouveau variant circulent et sa
séquence génétique n'a rien de rassurant
au micro comporte une cinquantaine de
mutation par rapport au virus originale
un nombre anormalement élevé le variant
delta par exemple en compte une
quinzaine
les experts s'inquiètent surtout de
l'emplacement de ces mutations
la majorité d'entre elles se situent sur
les spicules une protéine à la surface
du virus le spicules permet au virus de
s'accrocher aux cellules et les infecter
des mutations sur le spi qu'une aide le
virus a déjoué en partie le système
immunitaire même chez les personnes
vaccinées
par ailleurs au micron se répand bien
plus vite que le virus original et ses
autres variantes au québec ils
représentent 20% des cas de com et 19 le
12 décembre et ce taux grimpe à 80 % ou
est une semaine plus tard en revanche
les données actuelles suggèrent que le
variant micron cause des infections
moins sévère car il est affecté ses
mines différemment les coronavirus entre
chez d'humains par le nez et la bouche
en se multipliant
il descend de noms des voies
respiratoires
s'il se développe dans les poumons et
atteint d'autres organes vitaux des
complications graves peuvent survenir
au micron a toutefois changé de
stratégie plusieurs études préliminaires
remarque ce variant peine affecté des
poules il se développerait surtout dans
le haut du système respiratoire
ça contribuerait à expliquer plusieurs
phénomènes plus concentrés dans le nez
la gorge le virus fait moins de dommages
et se transmet plus facilement
[Musique]
à ce jour on ne sait pas à quel point la
vaccination freine ses transmissions
mais une chose est sûre les vaccins aide
le corps à se défendre contre au micron
une fois infecté ils rendent les formes
graves de kobe 19 moins fréquentes selon
une étude britannique les risques
d'hospitalisation serait réduit de 65%
après deux doses et de 81% après trois
doses
la vaccination permet donc de
désengorger les hôpitaux mais aussi de
prévenir l'apparition de nouveaux
variants car le virus mais plus
difficilement dans un organisme venant
en mesure de combattre
aussi selon une étude sud africaine les
personnes qui ont été infectées par au
micron posséderait les anticorps
nécessaires pour contrer la souche delta
la vague au micron pourrait alors freiné
et variant plus agressif et contribuer à
développer une certaine immunité dans la
population
les chances de voir la copie 19
éventuellement disparaître sont minces
mais la pandémie ne sera pas éternelle
pour autant
si la transmission diminue et se
stabilise sur une assez longue durée la
maladie sera déclarée endémique au même
titre que le rhume et la grippe mais à
christophe de pandemic bakchich fr lee
with all crise
au cours des prochains mois l'accès
mondial au vaccin sera l'ange taille il
jouera un rôle clé pour mieux contrôler
l'évolution du virus plus de 3 milliards
de personnes n'ont pas encore reçu leur
première dose
plusieurs acteurs seront aussi à
surveiller comme les quatre autres
variantes existent en classe est
préoccupant et l'arrivée de médicaments
pour traiter la coved 19
pour l'instant la suite des choses est
difficile à prévoir car le virus est
passé maître dans l'art de déjouer les
pronostics
mais nous apprenons de semaine en
semaine annuelle connaître
[Musique]
oui parce que dès le début cette
pandémie on croyait que la propagation
de la corvée se faisait uniquement par
les gouttelettes
l'exporter en toussant ou en éternuant
mais on sait maintenant et ça se
confirme de plus en plus que ce sont par
des aérosols ont joint une sommité en la
matière lydia bourguiba professeur
associé au prestigieux m a été de beauce
tombons soir alain boureau iba
bonsoir alors aérosols et au micro on a
l'impression que étant donné quand on
garde la transmissibilité de virus
maintenant avec au micro que c'est
devenu un cocktail explosif
est ce que c'est le cas selon vous
mais en fait la transmission par la voie
aérienne donc par l'air était là depuis
le début mais c'est vrai qu'avec au
micron il ya des parts propriétés qui
sont très effective pour 1 pour
atteindre
entre une très très rapide transmission
dans la population à l'intérieur et même
à des cas à l'extérieur parce que au
micron se transmet très rapidement et
vous même vous aviez déjà modéliser la
transmission par aérosol en 2010 avec le
strass et il semble qu'on a mis beaucoup
de temps à comprendre le rôle des
aérosols dans cette pandémie et ça c'est
une source de déception pour vous
pourquoi
mais en fait la recherche sur la
transmission des maladies par que vous
avez dit les grosses gouttes ou août let
versus aérosols en fait cette dichotomie
qui est en place finalement est basé sur
da de la science qui date du début du
siècle dernier 1930 est en fait bien une
série d'études et en entre autres celle
que nous avons menées en 2010 est ainsi
plus tard qu'ils ont clairement montré
que ce genre de classification en deux
roues tu
goûtes versus aérosols ne tient pas la
route même pour d'autres maladies et il
aurait fallu déjà un mettre à jour les
codes et les réglementations sanitaires
bien avant cette pandémie pour pouvoir
être plus flexible et pouvoir incorporer
la méthode de creep caution mais aussi
la science sur comment finalement
n'exhale et aimé des gouttes d'une de
taille qui sont continues entre 100
microns et petite tailles très
facilement et que beaucoup de choses qui
sont basés sur cette notion de grosses
gouttes versus petit ne tiennent pas en
réalité la route en même temps il ya eu
pendant des mois un débat entre
scientifiques plusieurs appelé à la
reconnaissance du rôle des aérosols
d'autres zones on n'a pas encore la
preuve absolue
vous mentionnez le principe de
précaution ici au canada dans plusieurs
provinces ce sera le retour à l'école
demain c'est déjà fait dans quelques
provinces mais il reste que le retour à
l'école en inquiète plusieurs parce que
il n'ya pas nécessairement la bonne
ventilation il n'ya pas nécessairement
les codes les balises dont vous avez
parlé vous avez déjà modéliser la
manière dont se transmet peut-être le
virus à l'intérieur d'une classe avec
des recommandations s'il voulait on va
regarder cette courte vidéo pendant que
je vous pose la question on voit une
classe on voit un point rouge au début
près de la porte d'entrée envoie notre
point rouge près de la fenêtre et on
voit le courant d'air qui se transmet
quel est le risque ici s'il y en a un
pour les personnes qui sont assises au
point rouge au début pas de la porte et
près de la fenêtre
oui donc là c'était une illustration en
fait basé sur des principes de dynamique
des fluides finalement montre que si on
ne porte pas de masque qui et empêche la
propagation donc ce petit nuage rouge
qui finalement se propose assez loin là
parce que la source ne n'a pas de masque
au bout d'un certain temps ça se propage
partout dans la dans la salle si on veut
augmenter la ventilation il faut le
faire r absolument mais il faut tenir
compte de certains principes de base qui
sont que si on place les individus à la
proche de la sortie de l'air ces
individus vont être exposés de manière
cumulative à l'addition de tous les
pathogènes qui sont en l'air puis ce
qu'ils auront finalement ils sont ils
seront au point de sortie et de manière
similaire si on a un point d'entrée qui
est trop localiser et mal finalement e
place et on reconstruit retrouvera avec
si on a un un des individus qui est
malade juste en face de points de source
d'air frais on va avoir une distribution
très efficace des virus cette personne
est en quelque sorte en étant la zone 2
de respiration sur tout tout sur tout ce
qui est à l'arrière de cette personne
qui est en amont là où mr freeze entre
est donc en fait il y à certains
principes de base quand on veut
augmenter la ventilation en classe qu'il
photos auxquelles il faut tenir compte
si ce n'est pas fait il de manière
mécanique au point de vue de
l'infrastructure mais plutôt avec par
exemple des purificateurs d'air et pas
ou des fenêtres tout simplement être là
la ventilation naturelle la lazio a
d'abord oui bah merci d'avoir parlé de
votre expertise avec nous ce soir
bonsoir
alors j'aimerais retrouver mon panel ça
vous interpelle c'est fascinant de voir
la différence entre les deux
possibilités une aération naturelle et
et mécanique qui peut justement prévenir
ce genre de problème quand elle est bien
faite vous savez que demain au québec
qui a déjà dû comme son scolaire qui
reporte la rentrée scolaire ou ici qu'on
envoie le message aux parents de deux
de donner aux enfants des chandails
parce qu'on va ouvrir les fenêtres c'est
important qu'à moins de deux mètres
d'une fenêtre entre eux sur le malin
bourguiba c'est un risque alors
j'aimerais votre réaction
j'aimerais commencer avec vous c'est le
comble et réactions sur
dans le fond on y compte que ça change
aussi dans notre approche de cette
pandémie des mesures qu'on doit
continuer à prendre ou pas c'était un
exemple été donnée par madame bruit ben
oui mais moi je trouve ça très
intéressant comme exemple de l'évolution
de la science à travers la pandémie
cette notion locon et de dichotomie
entre les grosses gouttelettes et les
petits aérosols c'était ce qui était
notre mantra jusqu'à présent en
prévention des infections et là on vient
de comprendre une notion qui est un
continuum et ça s'applique tellement
bien à au micron parce que au micro et
en plus contagieux alors ce continuum là
deux voies de transmission on le voit
dans la pratique dans la réalité
dernière chose que je voudrais rajouter
les leçons qu'on apprend d'une pandémie
ça doit nous servir à faire des
changements structuraux si on veut que
ça protège pour les parts des villes
suivantes donc depuis le début on dit
qu'il faut améliorer les systèmes de
ventilation dans les sièges celle des
dans les écoles alors si on met pas les
choses en place maintenant pendant qu'on
est dedans pendant qu'on on le sait
depuis qu'on le comprend j'ai peur que
plus tard on ne le fasse pas alors je
pense que ces notions le scientifique
c'est important que ça devrait guider
les décisions alors madame le maire
avons l'impression qu'on n'a pas écouté
les scientifiques on a pas appliquer ces
principes de précaution et que parce
qu'il y avait des leçons à tirer du
strass et des leçons qu'on aura attiré 2
la pandémie actuelle écoutez la science
a eu le dos très large au cours des deux
dernières années quand on prenait des
décisions
d'un côté ou de l'autre là mais je vais
revenir aux aérosols parce que c'est une
c'est une vraiment une question
fascinante qui vous montre comment des
dogmes peuvent se développer dans une
discipline et quand on creuse un peu
finalement on s'aperçoit que c'était
absolument aléatoire qu'il y a eu des
gens qui n'ont pas voulu avoir des
évidences devant leurs yeux que les
maladies respiratoires finalement se
transmettent par aérosol au début de la
pente de la de cette pandémie donc déjà
quand on a vu qu'il y avait de la
transmission asymptomatiques il fallait
se douter bien que ça se passait par les
aérosols et d'ailleurs où elle est et 20
20 j'ai convoqué un comité d'experts où
il y avait beaucoup d'ingénieurs de
physiciens de deux scientifiques de
l'environnement le il comprenait pas
qu'on soit encore dans un déni et qu'on
se pose la question est-ce que ça se
passe par l'air au sol ou pas on a donc
émis un rapport et des recommandations
le gouvernement fédéral a donné 2
décembre importante aux provinces pour
améliorer spécialement la ventilation
dans les écoles et voilà plus d'un an
après on en parle encore moi je trouve
que ça n'est un exemple où on sait d
opportunité manquée on a eu deux étés
pour améliorer les choses dans les
écoles mais il faut aller au delà des
écoles dans tous les endroits publics
l'an tous les milieux de travail via des
référés est mort soit laissé à celle des
ou tout autre milieu de travail est ce
que ça vous interpelle aussi le travail
que j'ajouterai une question à celle ci
c'est ça vous interpelle le cdc aux
états unis à confirmer ces jours
derniers pour pour certains travailleurs
l'importance du fameux masque n95 ici
les enseignants le réclament on
distribue à ses représentants au canada
mais il faut encore prendre des mesures
importantes pour freiner au micro et si
micron implique les aérosols il faut
prendre acte tout ça non
oui tout à fait je pense que la grande
leçon de tout ça c'est une leçon
d'humilité pour tout ce qui touche la
prévention des infections qui est reposé
sur des principes qu'ils étaient ici
comme l'a dit docteur bourguiba des
années 30 et sur la transmission de la
tuberculose donc on est clairement
aujourd'hui dans un monde où la
transmission par aérosol du de lakovic
19 est un mode de transmission important
qu'il ya une espèce de continuum qui est
nouveau et un nouveau concept et il faut
s'adapter à ces concepts là donc ça veut
dire plusieurs choses ça veut dire
d'abord que quand on sait pas il faut
utiliser le principe de précaution donc
il vaut mieux prévenir et ensuite voir
comment on peut s'ajuster deuxièmement
que bien sûr l'utilisation des masques
n95 qui au début était limité je vous
dirais jusqu'à un certain point a des
particularités dans le milieu de la
santé et c'est peut-être utile ce n'est
pas une panacée parce qu'un un bon
masque de niveau iii très bien utilisé
peut aussi être très efficace donc moi
je vous dirais le problème c'est plutôt
les gens qui utilisent tous les masques
en tissu entre guillemets artisanaux etc
dont on ne connaît pas l'efficacité et à
partir du moment où on utilise un masque
je dirais deux niveaux chirurgicale que
ce soit un masque de niveau 3 ou un
masque n95 mais il faut comprendre aussi
qu'un masque n95 c'est pas tout à fait
tout ce qu on a appelé le site test on
pourrait en discuter mais ça n'a pas
beaucoup d'importance relativement mêlée
c'est juste que c'est difficile de
porter pendant très très longtemps mais
au-delà de tout ça c'est tout un
ensemble de mesures qui va être repensé
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec dr
radi en termes de la pensée des
ingénieurs à revoir tous les aérosols
dans les bâtiments parce qu'encore une
étude respectueux publié ces jours
derniers une étude de la littérature
faite avant au micron qui depuis
confirmée par la très grande différence
entre les deux sortes de masques et vous
êtes bien de mentionner dr weiss que le
cdc disqualifie tous et masque en tissu
sont bien jolies bien mignon mais et
sont pas efficaces pour les élèves
reçoivent en n2 rapidement une question
du public et je
le dirige vers vous de terre trembler
les scientifiques ne parle plus que de
transmission par les pressions vient de
le faire de sport faut-il encore se
méfier des objets tels que les poignées
de portes les monnaies les papilles les
un panier d'épicerie dr tremblay est ce
qu'on se rend compte c'est qu'on a
observés pendant la pandémie que dans le
fond ce mode de transmission là ne
jouait pas un grand rôle pendant pendant
pour les nouvelles infections parce que
ça prend un certain temps ce qu'on
appelle une inoculum s'apprennent
quantité de virus suffisante pour
générer une infection alors mais c'est
quand même une bonne pratique de se
laver les mains de désinfecter les
objets parce que ça empêche beaucoup
d'autres microbes de nous atteindre et
ça fera partie des leçons qu'on va tirer
très certainement de cette pandémie est
de maintenir de bonnes habitudes on se
retrouve après la pause au retour la
vaccination des enfants représentent
encore difficile à ces grands défis et
on se demande en quoi elle est
importante elle est essentielle à tout
de suite
on poursuit cette émission spéciale
découverte en direct vous savez c'est
veille de rentrée scolaire au québec
c'est à moins que la météo en décide
autrement mais ça pose les questions
pour le mardi en ontario au manitoba et
en nouvelle écosse s'est déjà fait dans
quelques provinces de l'ouest et
ailleurs ça ne tardera pas et charles
avec ce retour en classe en pleine vague
au micron bien des parents s'interrogent
craignent les éclosions oui justement
c'est quand même quelque chose qui nous
interroge tous que doit-on faire vu
notre vivant bonsoir bonsoir chat ce
soir est ici pour vous en parler menace
entre collègues de découverte vais faire
un reportage là-dessus justement sur
toute la question de la vaccination qui
si importante par dean donc un peu de
votre démarche on a voulu un peu
répondre aux questions des parents et à
leur inquiétude parce qu'on voit par
exemple qu'en ce moment c'est à peu près
chez les adultes de 12 ans et plus au
canada c'est plus de 87% des personnes
qui sont vaccinées chez les enfants on
voit que c'est inégal ces variables de
région en région dans certaines régions
montréal en veille de rentrée scolaire
on est autour de 20 à 30 % de taux de
vaccination donc là on a voulu répondre
aux inquiétudes comment ça se fait que
les experts peuvent recommander avec
tant de conviction et tant de certitudes
cette vaccination est est ce que
vraiment il y à un bénéfice pour les
enfants à cette vaccination donc on
regarde ce reportage là
au canada 39 % des enfants de 5 à 11 ans
ont reçu leurs premières doses de vaccin
contre la co lead au québec c'est 56%
pendant ce temps des parents hésitent
encore
pourquoi vacciner les enfants alors que
pour eux les risques de la maladie sont
faibles en tire t'il vraiment bénéfices
doit-on les vacciner pour le bénéfice de
la collectivité
et comment la majorité des experts
peuvent-ils recommandé avec tant de
certitudes ce vaccin nouveau genre
malgré le peu de recul nous avons
rencontré plusieurs experts dont ceux
qui ont formulé des recommandations aux
gouvernements du québec et du canada
pour comprendre zoom sur leurs
réflexions ce qui a guidé leur choix
pour nous et pour leurs familles
9 novembre 2020 santé canada donne le
feu vert à pas d'heure bio ntech pour
l'emploi de son vaccin chez les enfants
pour rendre leur décision les experts se
sont penchés en particulier sur les
études de phase 1 2 et 3 mené par la
compagnie la qualité du vaccin et son
processus de fabrication
sur la base de ces données là il
considère que le vaccin est assez
efficace et sécuritaire pour pouvoir
l'administré ou le donner à la
population canadien
mais santé canada ne répond pas à ces
grandes questions est ce que les
gouvernements doivent recommandé ce
vaccin aux enfants à quel enfant avec
elle posologie
avec l urgence ces questions reviennent
à d'autres scientifiques indépendants
qui vont réanalyser les données et se
faire leur propre opinion
pour conseiller le gouvernement fédéral
c'est le comité consultatif national de
l'immunisation qui réunit une quinzaine
d'experts indépendants votant
au québec un autre groupe d'une
quinzaine de scientifiques indépendants
fait de même le comité sur
l'immunisation du québec dont fait
partie la spécialiste en santé publique
chantal sauvageau et la docteure couach
ce comité là est excessivement à l'affût
des données à une expertise en
immunologie et en vaccination qui est
incroyable en termes d' historique et de
connaissances et de compétences on
regarde toujours le fardeau de la
maladie l'efficacité de la vaccination
sa sécurité
les enjeux d'acceptabilité la conformité
ce qui se fait ailleurs les enjeux de
faisabilité les enjeux étaient le
paradigme avec lequel on part c'est pas
nécessairement dire le pharmaceutique
leur commande donc on fait pareil jamais
durables stamping mais c'est clairement
pas une décision qu'on prend à la légère
jamais
leur plus grande question est ce que les
enfants tireront un bénéfice direct du
vaccin car livré que pour eux les
complications de la coved sont très
rares mais on s'est rendu compte dans la
dernière année que les enfants sont
sujets à ce qu'on appelle le syndrome
inflammatoire multi systémique une
complication pouvant conduire aux soins
intensifs et mener à des
dysfonctionnements de multiples organes
le coeur les reins le foie les poumons
dans leur analyse les comités doivent
comparer les risques de la maladie au
risque du vaccin d'abord pour la maladie
les estimations prudentes évalue à un
cas de syndrome inflammatoire multi
systémique sur 3000 enfants infectés
le docteur elie haddad et pédiatres
immunologue à l'hôpital sainte-justine
puisque la maladie va donner un cas
grave sur un sur trois mais il faut
surtout pas que le vaccin il nous donne
une myocardite sur 3000 scolasse donné
ça devient idiot on est bien d'accord
lors de l'étude de pfizer biotech de
phase iii plus de 3000 enfants ont reçu
le vaccin ils sont comparés à un groupe
témoin d'enfants non vaccinés
on me sens très peu d'effets secondaires
aucun grave et surtout pas demi au
quartier cette inflammation du coeur qui
avait été observé après la vaccination
des jeunes adultes le risque de
réactions sévères et donc probablement
inférieur à 1 sur 3000 par précaution en
considérant les marges d'erreur les
experts l'évaluent à moins de 1 sur 1000
mais ce risque est il plus petit que les
risques de la maladie de 1 sur 3000
l'essai de phase i hope you and take ne
suffit donc pas à déterminer
par contre on a de plus en plus de
donner ici au québec aux états unis et
en israël quelques autres mais cesser
les plus solides qui montrent que chez
les adolescents il y a eu des mots car
dit suite à la vaccination rapportés
mais essentiellement chez le groupe des
plus vieux donc chez les 15-17 très peu
dans le groupe des 13 14 ans 12 encore -
f
en israël sur 5 millions de personnes
vaccinées on a recensé 136 myocardite
c'est environ un cas sur cinquante mille
et ce avec une dose trois fois plus
élevée que celle donnée aux enfants
en israël ils ont donné deux doses à 21
jours nous en donne deux doses à huit
semaines et les ontariens ont bien
démontré que des thierry cet intervalle
diminue le risque
enfin environ 90% de ces mis au caire
dit suivant un vaccin sont bénignes
traiter avec un simple anti
inflammatoires et du repos
contrairement au mieux au caire dit
posco vide souvent bien plus graves avec
des effets potentiels à long terme tout
indique qu'à court terme les bénéfices
connu pour la santé l'emportent sur les
risques du vaccin
mais qu'en est il des effets à long
terme
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on a pas de recul sur le
vaccin mais on n'a pas de recul non plus
sur la maladie les risques inconnus de
la maladie il y en a plein parce qu'on
n'a pas encore l'évolution à long terme
d'un virus covit donc c'est parce que ça
va donner deux ou trois ans on a des
études qui suggèrent qu'il ya une
atteinte du cerveau chez 3 patients ce
pas très réjouissant les vaccins les
effets secondaires à long terme que
j'aimerais bien être au courant d'une
étude de vaccins dans la vie avant la
coved qui montre qu'il ya des effets
secondaires à long terme des vaccins non
y'a pas c'est un boost à un moment donné
il peut y avoir une réaction immunitaire
fâcheuses lors de cette injection lassé
des effets secondaires au vaccin mais à
long terme j'ai jamais eu d'effets
secondaires des vaccins inventaire
d'accord mais jusqu'à présent aucun des
vaccins passée n'était à arn messager
c'est justement le fonctionnement de ce
vaccin nouvelle génération qui rassure
les experts quand on compare un virus
avec le vaccin et qu'on comprend comment
ça marche à aucun moment on peut dire je
préfère rencontrer le virus
d'un côté comme un enfant s'infecte il
reçoit des grands navires us complet
actif avec une vingtaine de type de
séquence daher n 10 points qui
permettent au virus de pénétrer ces
cellules et de se reproduire de l'autre
camp vaccine on injecte qu'un infime
morceau de ce virus un de ces arn
messager qui permettra ensuite à nos
cellules de produire brièvement une
autre petite partie du virus les
spicules cette présentation du spicules
au système immunitaire lui apprend alors
à reconnaître le virus
donc quelqu'un qui a peur de rencontrer
le vaccin puisque le virus contient
exactement la même chose comme arn
messager comme parti s'il a peur de
rencontrer de vaccins mais il faudra
voir encore plus peur de rencontrer le
virus parce qu'en rencontrant le virus
il va rencontrer ce cas dans le vaccin
est pire
après ce vaccin comme après un vaccin
plus conventionnel ou même une infection
la suite des choses est à peu près la
même rien de nouveau le système
immunitaire s'arme pour une prochaine
infection au frein dans ce cas une
protection contre les infections
symptomatique de 91% selon l'étude de
pfizer bio ntech la rn messager lui se
dégrade en quelques heures
cette technologie est scruté depuis des
décennies par des scientifiques de
multiples disciplines
j'ai pas entendu de collègues nous dire
écoutez nous on est vraiment inquiet
pour dans 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans aucune
alarme non plus du côté des
cancérologues le pédiatre infectiologues
jesse pape enberg explique ça prend un
stimulus nocifs
prolongé pour évoquer un cancer on parle
de tabagisme c'est pas fumer pendant une
semaine qui veut te donner le cancer des
poumons
l'exposition est tellement
restreintes dans le temps et en termes
de doses que il y avait aucune
possibilité
ce bateau physiologique pour penser
qu'un vaccin aurait le message et
pourrait causer un cancer depuis qu'on a
d'elle temps est encore pire avec
omicron tout le monde va l'attraper
c'est à peu près une certitude on va
tous rencontrer le virus et donc comme
on fait ce calcul bénéfices risques est
bien on en arrive à la conclusion assez
simple vaut mieux attraper le vaccin que
le virus ça il n'y a aucun doute là
dessus
il y aura une suite au reportage de ma
collègue dans un instant mais j'ai
posé la question docteur couach que vous
voyez dans le reportage est
effectivement docteur couach étaient des
questions qui sont venus en grand nombre
du public à quoi bon vous y répondez au
début du reportage l'on va la reprendre
quels avantages de faire vacciner les
enfants s'il n'y a pas de complications
graves avec l'aco vide il ya quand même
comme dr haddad le disais les
complications qui sont les syndrome
inflammatoire systémique de l'enfant
avec complication est en fait depuis la
sortie du reportage et des données qui
sont sortis qui démontre que
l'administration de deux doses réussi à
prévenir cette complication là donc ça
je pense que c'est quelque chose de fort
intéressant une bonne nouvelle ça
absolument par ailleurs comme dr haddad
le disais je pense qu'éventuellement on
va tous rencontrer le virus mieux vous
le rencontrez avec un système
immunitaire près et on le voit avec les
adultes ceux qui ont reçu deux ou trois
doses sont tout à fait protéger contre
les complications graves mais on sent
capable aussi d'avoir une infection tout
à fait bénigne souvent même
asymptomatiques mais comment faites vous
pour rassurer les parents les informer
ce qui est un argument plus fort qu'un
autre je pense que des gens partant il
faut expliquer la maladie il faut
expliquer la vaccination quand je parle
avec des certains parents qui ont des
soucis ils ont l'impression qu'on leur
force qu'on les force en fait à faire
vacciner leurs enfants alors que
vraiment c'est une offre de vaccination
donc on pense vraiment que le vaccin est
bon il ya personne qui est obligé de le
recevoir mais on espère aussi qu'avec la
vaccination on puisse permettre aux
enfants de reprendre une vie beaucoup
plus normal d'un point de vue scolaire
parce qu'à ce moment là une fois été
vaccinées ben là la quarantaine est
moins longue plus l'isolément et moins
longs les dépistages sont moins
nécessaire parce qu'on sait que l'enfant
est maintenant protégée et on l'a vu le
au secondaire à l'automne ya à peu près
pas eu d'éclosion sa excessivement bien
marché les jeunes ont repris leur vie à
peu près normalement et c'est vraiment
le but joue elle du programme de
vaccination pour les enfants mais
justement parce que vous avez entendu
depuis le début de l'émission c'est la
rentrée scolaire dans plusieurs
provinces au québec ça devrait pour
plusieurs centres scolaires enfin va
être remis à marc ici parce que si vous
suivez les informations vous allez voir
que des jaunes annonce à khouza tempête
la fermeture des écoles mais toutes les
mesures n'ont pas été prises par tous
pour assurer la sécurité des enfants
vous devez toujours plaidé pour le
bien-être psychologique et le
développement de l'enfant long terme
mais est-ce que ce tas d'arguments ça
c'est si on est dans un quartier où et
seulement 20% des enfants vaccinés on
devrait accélérer la vaccination dans ce
groupe on essaie d'accélérer d'accélérer
la vaccination c'est sûr qu'il ya des
programmes de vaccination scolaire et
des programmes de vaccination en centres
de vaccination aussi on essaie surtout
de vacciner les professeurs pour qu'ils
aient leur troisième dose et qu'il soit
bien protégée je suis tout à fait
d'accord que la ventilation est
peut-être pas maxime allemand optimisé
partout mais je pense que quand on
regarde comme vous le disiez le risque
versus bénéfices pour un jeune enfant
qui deux ans de sa vie c'est énorme on
sait qu'il ya des échelons à passer à
des moments bien prises et les moins de
5 ans rapidement où en sommes-nous on
attend encore les données de la
compagnie pharmaceutique donc on
s'attend à voir des résultats quelque
part au mois d'avril mais les études
sont encore en cours donc il est trop
tôt pour se prononcer merci beaucoup
docteur couach
de 9 ans il reste que cette deuxième
partie du reportage où nous amener un
peu ailleurs il ya le bien-être des
enfants psychologique c'est certain il
ya l'intérêt collectif oui clairement on
il faut bien comprendre avec les comités
aviseurs donc on a présenté c'est que
vraiment ils ont mesuré le bénéfice
risque pour chaque enfant et c'est pour
ceux qui font cette recommandation là
mais ce qu'on voit dans les
modélisations dont les modélisations
biénès pq c'est que bon ça réduit pas
les hospitalisations chez les enfants
mais on voit une réduction donc dans la
circulation que communautaire et dans la
circulation et dans le nombre de cas
lorsqu on vaccine les enfants et donc
sur ce je vous invite à regarder
la suite de notre reportage merci
beaucoup pour ce reportage vous en prie
un autre élément a pesé lourd dans la
balance des comités le bien-être
psychologique et social de l'enfant et
son apprentissage
honnêtement en termes comme pédiatre on
est beaucoup plus inquiet de ses impacts
là parce que ça va avoir un impact à
long terme surtout qu'on a vu cette
année les bénéfices de la vaccination
pour la scolarisation des plus grands
les adolescents de 12 à 17 ans
si on regarde à l'automne 2020 dont
dernier où il y avait personne de
vacciner c'était dans les écoles
secondaires qui avaient les plus grand
nombre d'éclosions suivez le primaire
suivait le préscolaire les garderies est
là depuis le début de cette rentrée ici
avec 80 % des adolescents qui ont reçu
les deux doses on a quelques corps qui
n'évolue pas vers des éclosions dans les
écoles secondaires
pendant ce temps les enfants ont été au
québec le groupe le plus touché à
l'automne c'est pour ces raisons que le
comité d'immunisation du québec a
tranché de manière unanime les bénéfices
du vaccin surpasse les risques ils
arrivent à la même conclusion que son
pendant fédéral que son thé canada que
la food and drug administration' aux
états unis et que l'organisation
mondiale de la santé quand je vois à
quel point ces débats sont intenses
intelligent bien fait ça me rassure
complètement le dit la probabilité que
tous ces comités sur la planète disent
la même chose et que cette même chose
soit fausse allez allez à peu près à 0
après d'intenses débats le comité a
choisi de recommander au gouvernement
d'offrir le vaccin aux enfants plutôt
que de vacciner les enfants une
recommandation ou moins forte que dans
les groupes plus âgés
y a rien d'obligatoire dans cette
recommandation là on a on sait bien
n'assurer que le vaccin n'est tête ne
serait pas attaché au passeport
vaccinale justement parce que le
bénéfice direct pour l'enfant c'est pas
la même chose que le bénéfice direct
d'une vaccination pour une personne de
65 ans et plus le seront on est on est
tout à fait d'accord avec ça
ce sera donc à chaque famille de faire
son évaluation comme le rappellent les
tice antoine payot ensuite la manière
avec laquelle on va décider de ce qui
est important pour soi dépôts de nos
propres valeurs de nos valeurs
familiales
un autre élément pourra aussi influencé
la décision le choix d'aider la
collectivité en se vaccinant pour
freiner la propagation globale du virus
les cheveux que dans les discussions on
voit que le bénéfice collectif soit
aussi un bénéfice pour soi même et ça
fait aussi partie du vivre ensemble
qu'on décide de se protéger soi-même
pour protéger les autres et ce ne sera
pas la première fois qu'on vaccine un
groupe pour en protéger un autre par
exemple on vaccine les enfants contre la
rubéole une maladie bénigne pour eux
mais grave pour les foetus des femmes
enceintes
la vaccination des enfants se déploie
sur tous les continents quand on tombe
dans les données du la vraie vie du vrai
monde le pharmaceutique n'est plus là
pour gérer les résultats c'est du vrai
de vrai aérien des puristes
les experts universitaires l' oms les
institutions gouvernementales traquent
les ai faits plus rares impossible à
déceler lors des études cliniques
précédente aux etats unis huit millions
d'enfants de moins de 11 ans ont reçu
leur première dose on n'a découvert
aucun nouvel effet secondaire grave et
rapporter un très faible taux ni au
caire dit bien inférieur à celui des
adolescents
ce vaccin va scruter mais à la loupe
c'est à dire qu'il ya en plus des
processus de surveillance qui existent
déjà qui sont robustes parce qu'on
détecte des des effets secondaires au
niveau planétaire au sto qu'il ya
quelque chose de nouveau la communauté
scientifique sais pas il ya un nombre
d'experts incroyable qui passe à travers
de ces données il ya une ombre de
reproduction incroyable de toutes ces
expériences donc plein de laboratoires
du monde entier ce soit la séquence du
virus la séquence de la rn message et la
façon dont les plasmas des patients sont
testés enfin en termes de neutralisation
en termes de toxicité
c'est certain qu'il arrive presque
toujours qu'on se pose la question est
ce que cette recommandation l'eau confie
d'un point de vue populationnelle ou au
meilleur de notre connaissance est-ce
qu'elle s'applique bien à nous est ce
que demain matin on est prêt à
l'appliquer chez nous ou pour soi même
tous les pédiatres que je connais nous
vacciner leurs enfants
on aime nos enfants je peux vous jurer
qu'on aime nos enfants on sait calculer
les risques sinon si on le fait pour nos
enfants pour nous nos nièces c'est con
parce que c'est safe comme tout le monde
me pose la question est-ce que je prends
la meilleure décision pour mon enfant
les données étaient là j'ai dit bon on y
va
c'est avec ce mec de dos c'est fini
[Musique]
mouais
alors tous les pédiatres ont fait
vacciner leurs enfants je retrouve les
invités docteur quoi joue mais vous vous
êtes posé la question oui d'être
rassurés vous même au fait oui oui mais
bon mes enfants sont plus grands le mais
effectivement nous regarder les données
puis c'est normal de se poser la
question je pense que c'est tout à fait
attendu puis il faut juste avoir les
informations les rendre disponibles pour
que les gens puissent décider eux aussi
pour leurs familles on va regarder le
taux de vaccination au canada si vous
voulez bien ensemble pour rafraîchir la
mémoire à nos téléspectateurs
83 % des canadiens ont leurs premières
doses 70 % la deuxième dose
77 % et 28 % la troisième dose est ce
que vous pensez que ce taux est un bon
taux de vaccination est est ce qu il
nous permet justement d'aborder cette
idée qu'on amorce un tournant quand on
aura une nouvelle approche avec avec
cette pandémie madame demeure bien
écouter le taux de vaccination est
certainement très bon puisqu'on se situe
parmi les meilleurs maintenant il faut
aller plus loin parce que l'immunité
collective
on ne peut l'avoir que par la
vaccination ou l'infection et comme on a
déjà entendu mieux vaut de loin avoir le
vaccin que l'infection est donc il faut
vraiment doublé de d'efforts là pour
vacciner tout le monde incluant les
enfants et là-dessus j'aimerais
peut-être juste rajouter que ce qui a
fait ce qui fait peur ou aux parents
pour les enfants de moins de 12 ans et
d'une part la myocardite comme comme on
a entendu et d'autre part bon le fait
que ce soit un vaccin à arn alors moi je
voudrais vous dire que pour les
myocardite les
le risque d'avoir une myocardite si on
est infecté et de sept à dix fois plus
élevé que si on a le vaccin donc il ya
déjà ça la deuxième chose c'est que la
rn et on l'a vu dans le reportage c'est
vraiment une molécule qui est très
instable et à partir du moment où elle
est dans la cellule et qu'elle a produit
la protéine elle va être dégradée donc
elles disent pas et a très rapidement
alors moi j'aimerais juste vraiment
encouragée et les adultes et les enfants
à être vaccinés et de travail et pas de
vaccin contre la désinformation ni
encore un bout de chemin à faire de ce
côté là même du côté de la recherche de
nouveaux vaccins
oui tout à fait alors d'abord il faut
dire qu'au canada on est très bien
vacciné l'a peut-être où le bât a blessé
un peu ça a été la vitesse
d'administration en ce qui concerne la
troisième dose surtout plaît peut-être
plus au québec que dans certains autres
provinces mais on s'adapte c'était
vaccin arn c'est comme un gâteau ou on
peut modifier la recette très très
rapidement et il suffit de modifier un
petit peu la recette pour avoir la
nouvelle variante la nouvelle version
améliorée du gâteau et comme on l'a bien
dit dans le reportage vous savez les
vaccins à rnc mieux d'attraper un vaccin
arn avec un tout petit morceau des arn
du virus que le virus au complet parce
que là vous allez avoir beaucoup d'ail
rennes et toutes les formes d'art reine
du virus donc la vaccination ce que ça a
fait il faut pas oublier et à peu près 9
9 milliards 700 millions de doses de
vaccins à date qui ont été donnés dans
le monde évidemment c'est pas tous des
vaccins arn certains sont beaucoup moins
efficaces en chine et en inde mais ce
qu'il faut se rappeler c'est que jamais
dans l'histoire de l'humanité on a donné
autant de vaccins aussi rapidement à
autant de monde et à autant de groupes
vous savez des fois les vaccins dans nos
enfants aux personnes âgées aux gens et
nino supprimés là on les a donné à tout
le monde et donc on a pu évaluer la
sécurité du vaccin sur des milliards de
personnes dans tous les groupes d'âge
partout sur la planète les hommes les
femmes les plus jeunes et plus vieux et
je vous dirai toutes les études pointent
dans la même direction
les avantages de la vaccination
l'emportent très nettement sur je vous
dirais les problèmes potentiels
d'ailleurs on le voit malheureusement ce
qu'on voit actuellement de plus en plus
c'est des gens non vaccinés relativement
jeune et qu'on voit très malades parfois
en soins intensifs
on en discutera probablement et on
pourra discuter de escaut micron est
vraiment d'ailleurs moins sévère que le
reste parce que quand ça affecte des
gens non vaccinés et on voit encore des
maladies sévères
oui docteur crash donc en tant que
pédiatre est ce que vous avez vu des cas
de très jeunes enfants très malades ya
eu des cas anecdotiques qui ont été
rapportés dans newton g a pas tellement
longtemps de médecins qui disait écouter
on a des très jeunes patients beaucoup
plus qu'avant et on s'inquiète alors
c'est anecdotique a pas une série
d'études là dessus mais quelle est votre
réflexion à ce sujet là je vous dirais
qu un peu comme les autres virus
respiratoires le très jeunes enfants
âgés de moins de six mois en particulier
qui est exposée soit par la fratrie pour
les parcs ou par les parents qui ne sont
pas vaccinés qui développe une qu'ovide
de façon précoce peut être relativement
malades avec problèmes respiratoires
intubation soins intensifs donc c'est
vraiment cette population allait chez
les enfants qui est le plus à risque de
développer des complications
respiratoires d'où l'importance de
vacciner les mamans quand elles sont
enceintes mais aussi d'essayer de
limiter la transmission intrafamiliale
quand on a des plus grands frères et
soeurs qui vont à l'école pareil pour
que par exemple qui peuvent être
vaccinés et ensuite limiter la
transmission intrafamiliale et aussi que
l essai clinique kaiser bio ntech
justement avec les enfants de moins de
cinq ans et on s'est rendu compte que le
vaccin ne portait pas de protection
supplémentaire n'augmentez pas les
anticorps protecteurs qu'est ce que ça
veut dire c'est ce que ça veut dire que
peut-être ce vaccin ne pourrait pas
fonctionner auprès des tout petits ou
les prochaines recherches pourraient
aboutir à quelque chose de plus positif
de près vous ou si le nombre de doses
nécessaires parce qu'on se rappellera
que quand on compare le nombre de doses
nécessaires j'ai un très jeune enfant
par rapport à un plus vieux ça prend
parfois plus de vaccins dans la dos
primaire est-ce que ça va être le dosage
qui ce qui sera différent c'est pour ça
qu'on ne peut pas conclure sur ces
résultats là tant et aussi longtemps
qu'on ne les avait pas vus et quand on
entend le ms déclaré qu'il faut faire
attention et et a fait l'homme est mis
en garde contre
la tentation de comparer ce qui se passe
actuellement un même dans le fond cette
pandémie là ce n'est qu'un rhume
si on bat réaction à ça parce qu'il ya
bien des gens qui vont dire à quoi bon
faire vacciner si je suis heureux de
toute façon à quoi bon faire vacciner
même les verts les vaccinés sont malades
de trembler moi je peux vous dire que
j'étais à l'hôpital aujourd'hui l'un
puis j'ai vu trois de mes patients qui
étaient relativement immuno supprimer
qui sont rentrés à l'hôpital pour une
autre raison testés négatifs à l'entrée
deux jours plus tard artistes positif et
24 heures après ils étaient rendus aux
soins intensifs alors pour ceux qui
pensent que c'est au micro c'est juste
un rhume c'est faux il faut vraiment
s'enlever cette vidéo micron peut causer
une maladie aussi grave que delta et ça
va être particulièrement vrai chez les
non vaccinés particulièrement vrai chez
les immuno compromis puis j'aimerais que
les gens pensent que je dis c'est quoi
que ça veut dire quelqu'un qui est
immunocompromises c'est des gens que
vous connaissez c'est une soeur qu'il ya
un cancer du simple que de
chimiothérapie c'est un oncle qu'un
cancer du pancréas puis qui il suit des
traitements depuis un bon moment c'est
quelqu'un qui est vih et picchio des cd4
très bas on connaît tous des gens dans
nos entourages ces gens là il faut les
protéger et puis si c'est pas une
motivation personnelle qui va faire en
sorte que les gens vont aller chercher
leur troisième dose je pense qu'il faut
penser à ces gens là qui vont être les
premières victimes finalement de cette
vague très rapidement d'accord couach
une question de l'ena chabot ou chabot
parce qu'il ya de la coved longue chez
les enfants en fait quand on regarde les
études jusqu'à maintenant par départ des
sondages où il manque en fait aux
enfants aux parents est ce que votre
enfant a eu perte de concentration
fatigue tout prolongé tout on s'il ya
quelque chose c'est autour de 2 à 4% ce
qui est intéressant par contre c'est
quand on compare ça à une population
témoin qui n'a pas fait la queue vide
les pourcentages rapportés sont à peu
près similaires donc ça se demander si
la copie de l'ong existe parce que ça
c'est pas clair chez les enfants les
symptômes la pourrait être due au
confinement l'école à la maison et à
tout le reste donc il n'ya pas de y'a
pas d'évidence clair que chez le jeune
enfant il ya effectivement une copie de
longues mais là tu merci beaucoup
d'acteurs couach on se retrouve après la
pause cette pandémie va t'elle s'achever
un jour est-ce qu'on va finir par sortir
de cette crise a tout de suite
on poursuit cette émission spéciale
découverte en direct avec charles
tisseyre on le disait avant la pause la
vaccination reste un grand défi mais il
ya de l'espoir du côté des traitements
qui serait prometteur contre la maladie
d'ailleurs le ms a recommandé vendredi
deux nouveaux traitements charles vous
allez nous expliquer tout ça commençons
avec les traitement à base d'anticorps
monoclonaux de quoi s'agit-il oui en
fait le médicament dont on parle là de
la part de nos msc lesautres ovi maps de
glaxosmithkline chaude et nordnet sont
difficiles à prononcer alors on se
concentre
un look score monoclonal au fond ce sont
des anticorps qui ont été créés
artificiellement et qui sont qui cible
directement les parties du virus qu'il
faut bloquer pour que le virus ne puisse
pas s'attaquer s'attacher à la scène
inhumaine on se souvient par exemple
dans le cadre d'un road show blue ridge
enron il a été un des premiers patients
recevoir ce site anticorps monoclonal
c'était en 1920
les calanques directement en 2020 et
puis on a vu qu'en 48 heures il s'est
remis alors ses autres scores
monoclonaux ont été utilisés au canada
et au québec continue à l'être d'une
certaine façon mais malheureusement le
ridge enron des autres de cette classe
là ne sont plus efficaces contre le
micro parce que le micron a muté mais le
saut trouve imams dont on vient de
parler l'huile et il est très efficace
il va chercher jusqu'à 79 % d'efficacité
auprès des patients qui sont à haut
risque d'avoir des complications si un
train placo vide on parle de personnes
âgées de personnes qui ont des
comorbidités de personnes qui sont en
dialyse ou des patients en oncologie qui
ont un système immunitaire qui est
compromis alors ces personnes là peuvent
être traités par par sept médicaments
mais il faut que ce soit diagnostiquée
en dans cinq jours il faut qu'on puisse
recevoir ce traitement rapidement c'est
une infusion par intraveineuse ça se
fait sous forme contrôler
dicale en clinique ou un hôpital donc
c'est prometteur mais il ya une certaine
lourdeur dans la façon de l'appliquer et
puis les médecins le vin les hôpitaux le
val mais on attend plus de doses on en a
reçu quand même quelques milliers mais
on en veut beaucoup plus et le fabricant
va essayer de le faire évidemment le
plus preuve le plus rapidement prévient
percée majeure avec pfizer oui messieurs
c'est une pilule alors ça c'est encore
beaucoup plus facile des pilules qu'on
peut prendre à la maison c'est un c'est
un médicament qui s'appelle pacs le vide
et il est efficace il est très
intéressant tout ça est préliminaire
bien sûr mais écoutez ses explications
de ma collègue gaël lucia berdou de
découverte qui va nous montrer comment
le le pacs le vide fonctionne
le virus du sras sco v2 a besoin de nous
pour se reproduire
quand ils entrent dans nos cellules son
matériel génétique et retranscrit en
protéines
d'abord sous forme d'une longue chaîne
qui doit ensuite être découpé en
plusieurs morceaux
le ciseau c'est une enzyme une protéase
pour stopper le virus dans sa
progression la molécule développée par
feu the block l'action de cette protéase
elle empêche les protéines du virus de
se former correctement et donc de servir
à fabriquer de nouveaux virus le
traitement appli pacs le vide comprend
aussi une deuxième molécules antivirales
habituellement utilisés contre le vih
qui ralentit l'élimination de la
première pour prolonger son action
l'essai clinique de phase ii a été menée
chez des gens qui n'étaient pas vaccinés
près de 1000 adultes âgés de 60 ans et
plus ou qui présentait au moins un
facteur de risque de complication grave
de lakovic 19 ont reçu le médicament
après avoir développé des symptômes de
la maladie et près de mille autres ont
reçu un placebo
soixante-six personnes qui ont reçu le
placebo ont dû être hospitalisés pour la
coved 19 dont 12 sont décédées alors que
huit personnes qui ont reçu le
traitement ont dû être soignés à
l'hôpital ça correspond à une réduction
du risque de 88%
alors il ya de l'espoir mais c'est pas
encore disponible au canada c'est à dire
la demande a été faite à santé canada
parfums dont on attend la réponse d'ici
quelques jours et ça va prendre des
ordonnances ou toujours que ce soit à
l'intérieur de cinq jours et puis il
faut que les médecins évidemment plus
diagnostiqué ainsi qu'au québec et des
milliers de gens qui n'ont pas de
médecin de famille c'est pas évident
mais au moins théoriquement si la whey
alors mais éviter que pensez vous de cet
arsenal de traitement et je commence
avec vous de te prendrai
très très intéressant et les antiviraux
ont le potentiel de changer la donne
dans la pandémie parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de transformer la pandémie en
une maladie endémique
ce qui impliquerait que quelqu'un qui
attrapé le virus on serait capable de le
traiter de soigner avec un médicament
alors là on en est aux premières
générations de ces médicaments là on
mangeait pas de doute qu'il va y avoir
des deuxièmes générations qui vont être
encore plus efficaces qu'ils vont
peut-être nécessiter moins
- l'ong administration et cetera même et
donc oui c'est très très intéressant on
donne nous sommes trop minable à
l'hôpital à nos patients
immunocompromises malheureusement on est
toujours à court de doses y en a eu
suffisamment et ont aussi que saleh un
impact alors oui ça l'est un grand
potentiel de changer comment va
percevoir la maladie si on doit des
médicaments pour la traiter vont
permettre la question je la pose avec
travail c'est en même temps être vous
obligé de vous priver de soigner un
patient avec ce médicament là parce que
vous n'êtes pas sûrs d'avoir là où on
sélectionne beaucoup les patients à qui
on décide de donner les doses de travail
ben oui on en donne du centre ovi maps
on en a donné au moins une soixantaine
dans mon hôpital mais j'aurais ans
j'aurais aimé en donner des centaines
pour vous donner une idée il ya à peu
près 200 milles traitement monoclonaux
par semaine qui sont donnés aux états
unis donc on est très loin en proportion
de ce que pourrait donner au québec il
va falloir dans le futur prévoir
probablement des centres d'infusion à
mon sens où on pourrait facilement
administrer ces médicaments là c'est pas
très compliqué administrés une fois que
le protocole est bien fait c'est quelque
chose qui se fait très rapidement ça
sedan dans une heure ça prend une heure
de surveillance alors c'est très facile
à faire mais mieux que ça il ya encore
des anticorps qui arrive aux états unis
qu'on peut donner en prophylaxie pré
exposition à des gens qui seraient très
à risque très malade qui ne répondent
pas aux vaccins mais à qui on pourrait
donner ces anticorps et finalement comme
disait ma collègue
le fait d'avoir des nouveaux médicaments
surtout même de première génération mais
on va en voir d'autres va changer
complètement de la donne en terme de
traitement en externe mais aussi
peut-être en termes de prophylaxie à des
gens qui par exemple ne répondrai pas
bien la vaccination des patients minot
supprimer ou lorsqu'on aura des
éclosions par exemple dans des centres
de soins prolongés donc on a une gamme
énorme qui s'ouvre devant nous et quand
on parlait de notre réunion 10 à 2 ans
par rapport à aujourd'hui
on a eu une explosion je vous dirais de
thérapie qu'on n'avait pas du tout avant
on n'avait absolument rien pour traiter
la co vide là on a des armes très
ciblées contre la copie ce qu'on avait
pas dans la première phase du traitement
de la maladie et dr weiss est ce qu'on
peut imaginer que l'on puisse recevoir
justement cet anticorps monoclonal
eux-autres ovi mahb de façon ambulatoire
oui tout à fait d'ailleurs ces données
de façon ambulatoire oui ça se fait très
rapidement les patients qui on le donne
c'est justement des gens qui ne
devraient pas être à l'hôpital c'est à
dire on donne à des gens qui ont des
facteurs de risque et chez qui on veut
prévenir une hospitalisation alors dans
le contexte actuel où on voudrait sauver
délit l'idée c'est de leur administrer
le plus rapidement possible une fois
qu'ils taisent positif pour la co vide
qu'ils ont des facteurs de risque en
dedans de 96 heures quand on leur donne
ce type de monoclonal on peut réduire de
plus de 75 % le risque d'hospitalisation
donc c'est le bénéfice de ce type de
thérapie la madame la maire votre
réaction quand on entend de médecins
cliniciens qui sont sur le terrain qui
luttent contre la connerie les entendre
dire qu'ils doivent faire des choix ils
ont 60 doses il y en aurait eu besoin de
ça il semble que c'est étonnant il
presque déconcertant dans pensez y à
écouter ce qui est étonnant c'est
vraiment le fait qu'on ait si peu d'anti
viraux que ce soit des antiviraux
spécifiques pour certains virus ou à
large spectre et on a absolument besoin
d'avoir plus de ces médicaments pour
justement lutter contre les prochaines
pandémies pour lutter contre plusieurs
infections virales pour lesquelles on a
vraiment pas d'outils en ce moment donc
le problème c'est que c'est un problème
d'approvisionnement en ce moment on
vient ça vient juste d'arriver il faut
les produire et cécilia tout le sa place
chez mais si vous permettez j'aimerais
juste d'être précisés et si pour ne pas
donner l'impression
au public que les antiviraux c'est un
substitut pour les vaccins parce que ça
ne l'est pas la meilleure façon en ce
moment de lutter contre la coved c'est
de se faire vacciner et j'aimerais
reprendre ce que mes deux collègues ont
déjà mentionné à propos de au micro
on dit un comique rond et plus et moins
virulent mais au fait c'est pas vrai il
est tout aussi virulent ou légèrement
peut-être moins que delta mais il est
dans une population qui est vacciné et
les vaccins fonctionne d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui il ya encore un manuscrit
qui est sorti une étude qui a démontré
comment les cellules t donc les cellules
mémoire qu'on a
lu très bien contre micron après surtout
trois doses d'ailleurs là beaucoup mieux
qu'après deux doses et donc ce n'est pas
un substitut mais pour être préparé et
pour la suite des choses parce qu'on va
avoir des éclosions oui il faut avoir
des antiviraux et le canada et le monde
a besoin d'accélérer à la fois la
recherche et la production d'antiviraux
c'est vraiment très très important et
c'est un manque dans notre arsenal si
vous voulez de médicaments pour lutter
contre les infections très bien très
bonne nuance est très important en effet
on nous répète sans cesse qu'il va
falloir apprendre à vivre avec ce virus
on commence déjà à gérer les risques
cette manière là mais charles ça veut
pas dire qu'on sera en pandémie pour
toujours bon en fait tôt ou tard la
maladie devrait passer au stade de leur
dis qu'est ce que ça veut dire
exactement comment arrive-t-on et bien
ce reportage sur ce scénario de
l'endémie regard ce sera suivi d'une
entrevue avec la directrice département
de la gestion des risques épidémiques à
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
[Musique]
plusieurs ont espéré que la vaccination
permettrait d'éliminer le virus de
lakovic 19 un peu comme on l'a fait avec
la variole ou du moins de le contenir
comme dans le cas de la rougeole mais
avec l'arrivée fulgurante de micron qui
déjoue notre immunité durement acquises
ces espoirs se sont évaporés le
consensus scientifique se consolide le
virus est là pour rester en d'autres
mots il deviendra endémique il sera
alors le cinquième coronavirus sa lettre
aux côtés des quatre autres coronavirus
qui causent les rues ou commun la
pandémie se terminera alors non pas par
une éradication du virus mais par une
transition vers une phase endémique
quand la maladie deviendra moins mortel
plus prévisible comparable aux grippes
saisonnières
les experts les plus optimistes
suggèrent que cette transition pourrait
survenir dans la prochaine année
qu'est ce qui permet de déterminer le
passage entre la phase pandémique et la
phase pandémique du virus il n'existe
pas de critères scientifiques exactes ou
définition universelle selon cdc
américains un virus et 10 endémique
lorsqu'il est présent de manière
constante dans une population avec un
taux d'infection relativement prévisible
et une circulation stable du virus pour
y parvenir la maladie doit atteindre une
forme d'équilibré avec notre immunité
collective simple et que près de la
totalité de la population est une forme
d'immunité acquise par la vaccination ou
par une infection cette immunité serait
alors suffisante pour empêcher des pic
de propagation mais insuffisante pour la
stopper car cette protection seraient
contrebalancées par la perte d'immunité
causés par son affaiblissement dans le
temps ou par les mutations du virus une
perte qui permet au virus de continuer à
circuler une situation bien différente
de la situation actuelle dite pandémique
ou de vastes groupes sont encore sans
immunité permettant encore des flambées
de la propagation plongeant à répétition
les systèmes de santé dans la tempête
[Musique]
des derniers siècles
nous avons vu plusieurs pandémique faire
cette transition la grippe espagnole de
1918 après trois vagues mortel est
devenue une grippe saisonnière endémique
encore avec nous aujourd'hui il ya eu
aussi le sida et la grippe porcine ce
sont des manadiers avec lesquels nous
avons appris à vivre dont nous avons
évalué les risques et desquels nous
savons protéger les plus vulnérables
pour les gouvernements reconnaître que
le virus devienne rap endémique c'est
cesser de penser qu'il y aura une date
de fin c'est se préparer une transition
vers une gestion d'une vie avec l'aco
vie de plus en plus de pays parlent
d'une transition prochaine vers une
phase endémique en particulier depuis
l'arrivée du variant au micron dantun
hospitalisation semble inférieur aux
variants précédent et qui fait miroiter
une situation un jour plus gérable il
infecte à grande vitesse la population
accélérant son immunisation aussi à ses
débuts le risque d'aider c'est de là que
vides étaient cinq à dix fois supérieur
à celui de l'influenza mais avec la
vaccination et l'arrivée des traitements
antiviraux les scientifiques espèrent
qu'on pourrait réduire les risques de
dessins de plus de 90% par rapport à
2005 ce qui pourrait abaisser ce risque
à moins de 0,1 pour ça un niveau
similaire à celui de la grippe
l'arrivée de l'endémie se profile
l'espagne et le royaume uni ont suggéré
dans derniers mois considérés par ces
prochainement à une gestion plus adapté
à une maladie endémique se rapproche
davantage de celle de la grippe
on est face à une véritable percée aux
états unis des membres du groupe de
travail sur la gestion de la qos vide du
président byden ont publié la semaine
dernière trois articles scientifiques
dans lesquelles ils réclament la mise en
place d'un plan national pour mener
cette transition
mercredi en réaction à ces annonces le
ms mettait en garde contre une
transition trop rapide
un gamin aussi le chemin vers la phase
endémique ne sera pas forcément direct
ou facile
rien n'empêche au cours des prochains
mois l'émergence de nouveaux variants
échappe à notre immunité plus virulents
cousant à nouveau des pics de mortalité
ne
savons pas à terme de quoi aura l'air la
coved endémique sa sévérité sa
transmissibilité le rythme auquel et
n'échappera aux vaccins certains
spéculent qu'elle pourrait un jour
devenir aussi bénigne que les
coronavirus qui causent rhume mais elle
pourrait aussi continuer à peser lourd
sur le système de santé comme la grippe
saisonnière pandémique depuis longtemps
et qui pourtant est une des causes les
plus importants de mortalité dans les
pays développés
on s'attend donc en 2022 à ce que ces
discussions occupent de plus en plus de
place comment et quand opérer la
transition
comment se préparer à cohabiter avec le
virus de l'aco vide comment passer de
l'état d'urgence d'un virus pandémique à
la gestion d'un virus pandémique
[Musique]
dr briand bonsoir bienvenue a découverte
en direct sommes très heureux de vous
recevoir parce qu'on veut connaître au
fond le passage s'il y en a un de la
pandémie allant des mii quels sont les
scénarios que vous envisagez
en fait c'est toujours très compliqué
parce que c'est difficile de prévoir le
futur mais en se basant sur les
expériences qu'on a sur d'autres virus
il ya schématiquement trois scénarios
possibles le premier le plus favorable
c'est que effectivement ce virus
devienne quelque sorte un virus
pandémique comme les autres quatre
autres coronavirus endémique que l'on
connaît qui va provoquer effectivement d
une maladie bénigne et qui va donc
circuler rapidement dans la population
le deuxième scénario c'est plutôt un
scénario qui ressemblerait à la grippe
et la grippe saisonnière comme vous
savez donc on a des épidémies et et
danser épidémie il ya des gens qui
malheureusement sont pas risque d'avoir
des formes graves de la maladie et d'en
mourir chaque année avec la grippe on
entre 6 450 mille six cent cinquante
mille personnes qui meurent chaque année
de la grippe donc ça demande quand même
un programme de lutte assez bien
organisé et le troisième scénario qui
est un peu le scénario catastrophe c'est
à dire qu'on va avoir d'autres variant
qui font émerger qui seront différents
des variantes qu'on connaît et donc ça
va demander compte mettre en cause les
outils qu'on a déjà c'est à dire qu'on
revoie un peu les vaccins les
traitements etc donc ça c'est scénario
catastrophe on l'espère absolument pas
évidemment mais il faut quand même
toujours se préparer et être vigilant et
le premier scénario c'est plus favorable
aussi mais malheureusement ne sait pas
quand ça va venir ça peut prendre quand
même plusieurs variantes
évidemment la science a fait des progrès
extraordinaires depuis deux ans on nous
dit beaucoup justement que la
vaccination a sauvé peut-être même des
millions de personnes il reste que si on
insiste encore à une course au vaccin
cette course au vaccin l'om est ce un
regard particulier vous fait un appel
aux scientifiques pour peta est orienté
cette course là de quoi at-on besoin
justement pour nous et des ajustements
dans ce scénario peut-être catastrophe
auquel on peut s'atteindre mais qu'on
espère qu'il n'arrivera pas
oui la course au vaccin en fait elle a
deux visages le premier visage c'est la
lutte contre les inégalités et s'assurer
que tout le monde ait accès aux vaccins
tous ceux qui en ont besoin et la
deuxième course effectivement c'est
essayer d'avoir des meilleurs vaccins
donc soit des vaccins qui
justement et une plus grande efficacité
en utilisant les plateformes qu'on a
déjà et qui sont déjà utilisés en
particulier par exemple en adaptant la
composition du vaccin aux variants qui
circulent mais aussi l'autre espoir
qu'on a c'est peut-être avoir un vaccin
qui soit beaucoup plus efficace sur la
transmission de la maladie pour
l'instant on a des vaccins qui sont très
bons pour prévenir les maladies graves
et protéger les gens les empêcher d'être
hospitalisée et de mourir mais on voit
bien que les vaccins qu'on actuellement
ne sont pas aussi efficaces que l'on
aimerait sur la transmission puisqu'on a
encore beaucoup de cas et spécialement
avec au micro en même temps vous avez
évoqué l'inéquité vaccinale on apprend
aussi par l'om est ce que des millions
et des millions de doses ont été jetés
littéralement parce que par la cre en
raison de la crainte qu'ils soient
périmés dans certains pays
on en est ou sur cette équité ou
inéquité vaccinale
ont disons qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
progrès faits puisque le kovacs
annoncent qu'ils ont réussi à distribuer
pratiquement 1 milliard de doses dans
les pays en développement donc je pense
que ce le l'inéquité est en train de se
combler enfin comble ce
déficit d'équité mais c'est vrai que
c'est cet art et puis il faut maintenir
absolument
la livraison de ces vaccins parce
qu'effectivement bon parfois on est pas
on ne peut pas utiliser tous les vaccins
qui ont été livrées pour diverses
raisons des raisons logistiques des
raisons matérielles des raisons qui sont
liées aussi à la faiblesse des systèmes
de santé dans votre pays et aussi le
fait qu'il ya un absentéisme dans l'est
dans le secteur des soins qui fait qu'
on peut pas nécessairement vacciner
aussi vite que vous voudrez toute la
population donc de tenir compte aussi de
tous ces empêchements qui sont liées à
la pandémie liée à des déficits
structurels aussi dans certains pays et
donc cher avec tout ça pour essayer de
s'améliorer en continu mais je crois
quelque chose que certains dans l'esprit
des spécialistes de ms et vous d'octobre
et on sait qu'on ne peut pas contrer
cette pandémie qu'avec des doses de
rappel nous ici on en est à la troisième
certaines villes une ville au canada en
est à la quatrième dose on est ce qu'on
aura un cinquième une sixième dos c'est
pas la voie à suivre selon vous
non non tout à fait parce que d'abord
c'est très coûteux et puis c'est
embêtant et en plus on a on ne comprend
pas très bien non plus les effets à long
terme d'avoir des doses répétées de
vaccins donc on pense que c'est beaucoup
mieux de se pencher plutôt sur le
produit le vaccin lui-même et voir
comment pour améliorer le produit pour
que justement l'immunité conférée par la
vaccination durent plus longtemps et
aussi nous permettre d'éviter toutes les
formes de la maladie pas seulement les
internats vous avez évoqué les trois
scénarios mais évidemment on espère le
premier on pourrait vivre le troisième
quand c'est avec un signal pourrons-nous
d'urbain concluront les pensées de la
pandémie allant des nippes et qu'elle
est le plus grand progrès que vous
espérez pour la science pour mettre fin
à cette pandémie
alors c'est difficile de donner des
dates etc parce que comme vous avez
compris le virus s'adapte et nous aussi
on s'adapte donc c'est un petit peu
comme ça un marathon en fait je pense
qu'on est on est certainement dans les
derniers kilomètres de ce marathon mais
je ne sais pas encore je vois pas encore
la ligne d'arrivée ça c'est clair ce qui
est sûr c'est que dans notre boîte à
outils pour lutter contre la pandémie on
a de plus en plus d'outils on a tous ces
vaccins y en a encore beaucoup qui sont
à l'état de deux phases près qu'il est
prêt mise sur le marché en tous les cas
et donc on va certainement dans les mois
à venir aussi avoir plus de vaccins plus
d'opportunités donc je crois qu'on est
vraiment sur la pente favorable mais
très difficile de prévoir donc je pense
que les progrès pour la science ce qu'on
espère c'est vraiment justement que on
est des meilleurs vaccins que ce soit
avec les plateformes actuelles ou
d'autres plateformes qui pourrait
arriver dans le futur des meilleurs
traitements aussi qu'on en ait plus à
tous les stades de la maladie et on
aimerait aussi avoir des tests qui
puisse servir dans différentes
circonstances notamment des tests
rapides qu'ils soient beaucoup plus
fiable comme ça on pourrait en fait
ajouté à notre boîte à outils et faire
en sorte que même si cette maladie reste
encore une maladie grave qui
malheureusement tu encore des gens on
pourrait apprendre dans notre monde du
21e siècle à vif de mieux en mieux avec
est justement réduire son impact non
seulement sur la santé mais aussi sur
nos sociétés nos écoutes de alors je
retiens de tas brillant qu'on doit
rester très prudent on doit rester quand
même optimiste et donc en ce sens garder
espoir pour cette année 2022 de thomery
un merci beaucoup tout à fait donc merci
beaucoup au revoir
dernier tour de piste avec mes invités
l'eau metz ne voit pas la ligne
d'arrivée qu'en pensent mes invités
surtout les châles poser les questions
dans son reportage quand et comment
doit-on entreprendre cette transition
comment on va vivre avec le virus et
vivre tout court et j'ai une pensée pour
tous ceux qui en souffrent encore de la
coved ceux qui en souffrent sur le plan
économique culturel tous ceux qui sont
marche visé par cette cave docteur
tremblay il ya plusieurs d'entre nous
qui pensons que le vih est encore une
pandémie et il ya deux millions de
personnes par année qui meurent vih et
les oubliés faut pas les oublier parce
que on n'a pas de on a pas de vaccin
contre le vih alors que pour la co vide
on a un vaccin et la transition d'une
pandémie vers une pandémie
va certainement passer par des vaccins
plus efficaces encore mais aussi ils
sont efficaces quand on les met dans les
bras des gens l'autre l'autre dernier
élément que j'aimerais dire faut aussi
éviter les montagnes russes
émotionnelles de la population en se
faisant des fausses joies paix en
pensant aux le pic est arrivé que la
semaine prochaine on va passer en un an
et demi c'est pas comme ça que ça va se
passer on a encore du chemin à faire
mais il faut comprendre que la science
nous a même de plus en plus d'outils qui
vont nous permettre de gérer alors les
médicaments qui sont bien les nouveaux
vaccins tout ça va nous permettre de
transitionner mais s'abrite sur un long
terme pas sur du court point 2022 la
commande pense aux états unis dr weiss
bah écoutez on la ligne de démarcation
entre la pandémie l endémie n'existe pas
n'est pas tranché au couteau ça va être
un passage qui va être fluide et graduel
entre le a et le b ce qu'il faut quand
même dire c'est que les vaccins contre
lacko vides sont beaucoup plus efficaces
que ceux contre l'influenza ont réduit
la maladie sévère de façon très
importante donc on a fait des progrès
qui sont énormes à date on a beaucoup
d'armes thérapeutique dans notre dans
notre poche et vous savez par à titre
d'exemple en 1889 il ya ce qu'on a
appelé la grippe russe ou de rachid flou
et on pense que c'est probablement un
coronavirus qui s'appelle aujourd'hui
l'os et 43 et qui est responsable d'un
simple rhume dont on voit que c'est
coronavirus évolué avec le temps et donc
à un moment donné devient beaucoup plus
bénins donc s'il faut se rappeler de
tout ça c'est qu'on va passer d'une
pandémie à une endémie on l'a peut-être
déjà commencé mais on ne sait pas encore
mais ce qui est certain c'est que c'est
une course de longue haleine et il sait
très important qu'on soit préparée d'un
point de vue sociétal à affronter les
prochaines vagues de façon différente de
ce qu'on a fait durant les dernières
vagues parce qu'on ne peut plus
continuer à avoir une société fermée
fracturé etc on n'est plus du tout dans
la même chose dans le même schéma de
pensée pour les plusieurs des dernières
vagues ou d'autres vagues à venir mais
madame nemer en terminant on avait prévu
prédisent certains avaient prédit qu'ils
auraient une pandémie on n'était pas
vraiment prêt alors comment comme
conseillère scientifique en chef du
canada vous pouvez vous influencer les
autorités pour qu on se prépare à vivre
cette transition l'a peut-être prévoir
tirer les leçons prévoir les autres
points ben oui a coûté ce qu'est ce qui
est un peu malheureux dans dans tout ça
c'est la façon qu'on n'était pas prêts
pour au micron à l'heure ça nous donne
une idée de ce qu'il faut faire et
mettre sur pied pour être prêt à
affronter
les prochaines pandémies
écoutez moi je suis optimiste quand on
regarde l'histoire la déco rona virus
humain
je crois que on est sur la bonne piste
bon je suis d'accord il n'y a pas une
ligne d'arrivée il n'y a pas un mois
qu'on peut prédire mais on va dans la
bonne direction ceci étant dit ce virus
nous a déjà joué des tours mais il faut
être prêts pour le pire il faut avoir un
système de surveillance de dépistage et
surtout un système hospitalier solide
pour pouvoir nous permettre de reprendre
une vie normale avec le virus et encore
une fois c'est la vaccination qui est
importante c'est pas juste les vaccins
tous les 3 comment vous remercier au nom
de l'équipe de découverte d'avoir
participé à cette émission ce soir avec
votre optimisme et vos connaissances
étaient extrêmement précieux pour
remercier également docteur couach alors
merci à vous trois c'est certain qu'on
se revoit bientôt qu on se recale gento
alors voila si tu ouvres cette émission
spéciale en conclusion on peut retirer
après deux ans de pandémie tout n'est
pas noir charles il ya de l'espoir
mais la date de fin est encore
incertaine là comme toujours toute
l'équipe de découverte va continuer à
suivre les progrès de la science on sera
là ont reçu ce dossier et je pense que
je vous promets qu'à 24 60 aussi sur une
base quotidienne on va le faire on est
toujours inspiré par l'équipe de
découverte alors merci beaucoup chardome
avoir reçu à découverte ah bah merci
beaucoup et de la ri de nous avoir
invités tous ensemble les journalistes
les réalisateurs il nous faut graver
toute l'équipe nous sommes ravis
d'europe picoterie alors continuez de
nous suivre sur toutes nos plateformes
dames messieurs il ya beaucoup
d'informations à chaque jour à chaque
heure sur la coved et bonne rentrée
scolaire à ceux qui rentrent à l'école
demain attention la tempête dans
plusieurs régions du québec merci de
votre attention et à bientôt merci
charles bonsoir